On September 21st, Japan's space agency made history.
It became the first country to land not one, but two rovers onto an asteroid,...
...and already, the two unmanned rovers have sent back the first images while on the surface.
And no, so far, it's looking like there are no alien cities on its surface,...
...but this mission, called Hayabusa2,...
...could ultimately help solve one of the grandest scientific mysteries of all,...
...where did life on Earth come from?
Scientists have been studying asteroids for years.
NASA, for example, landed its NEAR Shoemaker spacecraft on Asteroid Eros in 2001,...
...but it's Japan's space agency that is the first to deploy a pair of rovers...
...to explore an asteroid's surface.
Japan launched the Hayabusa2 mission in December 2014,...
...so, it has already been about three and a half years in the making.
The spacecraft rendezvoused with its target in June 2018,...
...snapping a series of pictures that revealed the asteroid's shape.
The asteroid of choice was 162173 Ryugu, or Ryugu for short.
In Japanese, it refers to a magical, underwater dragon palace.
Now, the asteroid flies through space around the sun every 16 months,...
...conveniently, between the orbits of Earth and Mars,...
...making it an ideal target for this mission, which, if all goes according to plan,...
...it will return a sample of the asteroid to Earth by the early 2020s.